if anybody wants to ask me a question
anything in the whole world
i'm game first up we actually have a
question from someone on twitter
julie from philadelphia tweeted us you
and debbie gibson were a riot
awesome if you could be in any musical
ever what would it be
uh julie that is the best question hi
virtual friends
oh gosh that's a really hard one and a
brilliant one i will go with greece one
and two
i loved stephanie zinoni uh michelle
pfeiffer is the hottest thing ever
um although i'm kind of like frenchy and
rizzo mixed together so um let's get a
question from our virtual friends
um let's bring up liz byer
hi true i love you and i love the show
and mike i love you and i love
everything about you too
and my question has to do with travel i
i know you've traveled a lot around the
united states do you have a favorite
spot
oh that's a good question um
you know what uh there is a philosophy i
have with my daughters
and uh i will get a tattoo of it one day
or make a neon sign and it is
home is where we are and
i figure wherever we travel to or we've
had to move across the country
we've been on many adventures but as
long as we're together
home is where we are and other than that
i love like a good ojai california
you